I have always been interested in what
makes form form like how things that we
see in the world become that way I guess
that's what it means to be a radical and
i proudly consider myself to be a
radical because the the root word of
radical is rad which is the same route
as radish and it means route so a
radical is someone who tries to get to
the root of something or to uncover
causes and not just be content to live a
superficial life or wrapped up in in
symptoms I was a librarian for a short
time at an esoteric library the
Theosophical library in Seattle and
during that time I read a lot of Eastern
philosophy and books on yoga i read the
yoga sutras because all of this was
available in the library that i spent
many many hours in and when i was a
dance to student at the University of
Washington I also started to take
classes in Indian philosophy and Indian
culture and studied Indian dance there
an Indian music and so this opened up a
whole other world that was a very
spiritual spiritually inclined younger
person I was raised Catholic but none of
the other my other family members really
embraced their religion and I was the
only one that went to church and I
walked there and you know so I have this
this kind of a spiritual unrest or
yearning always am
so one time I read the times in the
patanjali yoga Sutra the first Sutra
says etta yoga national and this is yoga
now attar means now and now this is yoga
as I have observed it in the natural
world around me that was like oh my god
because what he was saying was such a
positive and optimistic way to begin
this whole discourse of yoga it was so
optimistic and positive because it
implied that any one of us could come to
this yoga or this realization as yoga is
really the realization of how we are all
connected it's the realization of the
oneness of being that is what is
realized in the enlightened state that
is what all the practices of yoga are
geared towards experiencing and so when
he said that implying that any one of us
could experience this realization of the
oneness of being of the
interconnectedness of all things and
beings if we were willing to look deeper
into things if we were willing to go to
the cause the underlying cause which
basically answered my question about
what makes form form what brings things
about
you